sir [ __ ]
I said some hos yes hey what's up you
have a [ __ ] pygmy phone oh how dare
you animal abuse animal abuse yeah this
right what are you looking at my car
[ __ ] get out that's right [ __ ] is my
car wow I shouldn't be a [ __ ] chimp
man today is a good day
look at that ass oh I'm sick and tired
of humans trying to tell me what to do
ain't nobody [ __ ] with the chicken ain't
nobody [ __ ] with a chicken stop these
vehicles never mind
this is the greatest thing I ever seen
in my life what the [ __ ] is happening I
can't get out the sidewalk yes let me
get my rat ow
oh my my feet are not tall enough I
can't reach the pedals
hashtag chicken problems okay cool
alright then that's cool oh yeah that's
right you don't [ __ ] with a [ __ ] oh my
god can't [ __ ] see hey yeah that's
right [ __ ] can't pull the trigger
though what about the need oh god I
think I did something I trashed
no man [ __ ] sake
yeah what's up it's through 1/8
haha that's right [ __ ] alright
alright time for Peter to get some
action I want some ass it's time for
some yes baby yeah yeah we're all the
[ __ ] aye that's right
a [ __ ] you up oh okay going in
can I please write it go piggy go yeah
piggy Papa village I'm going to piggy
land whatever that is this is for eating
bacon oh god [ __ ] what happened what was
that oh god they should bake it down I'm
fine
I'm [ __ ] fine I wonder if we can be
the fish now yeah yeah I always wanted
to play Grand Theft Auto SF fish fishy
things [ __ ] bad hoes and tricks a lick
on these notes insulted Magikarp that's
all I can do goddamnit I'm so close but
so far away hey don't shoot a fish who
shoots a [ __ ] fish
you're insane come here I'm gonna use
splash on you [ __ ] how [ __ ] dare you
shoot a fish your mom's a fish yeah
that's right because I [ __ ] her it
you're my son
I'm a fish come on I'll get there one
day to the sea baby to the see that a is
that [ __ ] ears give me that
eat what's this oh god no alright [ __ ]
off tourists
Wow [ __ ] yeah go chicken go chicken
power ah [ __ ] hell
never mind all right friends had a lot
of fun today leave a like if you enjoyed
this well click here for more similar
videos and I'll see you in the next one
that's always thinking was watching stay
awesome breasts
what's that [ __ ] was that
hockey ice the [ __ ] ice can just
oh god I'm stuck
No